one of the stars of mr mayor that's on
nbc
uh thursday nights at eight eastern time
and you could stream it right here on
peacock the next day
bobby moynihan here on the show how are
you bobby good how you doing man hi
everything i'm doing fine so you're from
you're from westchester that part of new
york city new york yes
i am eastchester in westchester it's
nice to hear a bunch of shout outs i was
so happy to hear about lake isle
i used to work there okay so were you
like a caddy there in the golf course
i was a lifeguard how a lifeguard for
many years yeah
so were you the lifeguard on caddy day
in the pool at that uh
no i did drive a golf cart into the
kiddie pool once but
hold on a second now are you serious is
that really
very serious oh we did it all the time
for fun but i did it once
but i did it once by accident and um
how long how much longer were you
employed at that esteemed uh golf club
i was there for many years that was the
least of the things i did wrong
this is like caddyshack all over again
are you a fan of any particular sports
team bobby from up there at all yes no
uh uh the born and bred giants fan half
have to be from my dad yeah
yankees as well probably rangers but um
yeah i think that's it silence no i'm
taking it all in right now
no i'm taking it all in so did you who
are you were you like a lawrence taylor
fan growing up or phil sims guy or what
was your name
joe morris that very big very very big
in our lives
okay so that's pretty cool a kid from
westchester uh getting a gig on snl that
had to be
uh pretty amazing for you bobby uh yeah
it was
uh my live stream my dad really realized
that really was very proud of me when he
met eli manning that was when uh
[Music]
okay now that's when eli was the guest
host there correct
uh yes yeah uh peyton manning had hosted
a couple times but that was
before my time and then eli manning was
there when i was there
okay so who is the best athlete host of
snl that had the best comedic chops
oh wow um i i don't know about that i
would have to say
charles barkley might be the most fun
just because we did
we did a lot of drinking until early
hours in the morning afterwards
oh yeah so at the post party is what
you're the
i've been to one or two of those those
go to like three four in the morning
back in the day right uh yeah i would i
i
back in the day when i was you know
young and still full of hope
i would get home like sunday afternoon
so which how did you get uh how did you
get the gig in snl how did you
uh get the the call how did you gosh i
have no idea
um um uh i uh
you know uh did comedy went through you
know the channels and
they saw me i got to audition and got
super lucky it was like
i still don't believe it so you just got
a phone call
and and that and that uh and then
suddenly you showed up
it was 14 months of torture it was like
i almost got it got it
and then the writer strike happened and
then after a very long time
of trying and trying i got a call from
lauren just saying like yeah you had no
articles are you soon and i was just
like oh okay
and then the next thing you know i had
done five shows already
bobby moynihan here on the rich eisen
show uh of the characters that you have
played if i'm not
if i'm not mistaken belichick you've
portrayed bill belichick on in snl
yeah i think i have yeah yeah i i always
ended up playing a lot of of of
coaches so jimmy johnson i don't know if
that ever made it on air i played a lot
of
a lot of guys like why do you think that
is bobby i mean what why do you think
that uh
they turned to you for for the cause
what do you think mostly shape
i would say
so so what did you how did you practice
for your uh for your belichick how did
you did you go to tapes did you go
how did you how did you how did you get
ready for your bill i i
probably yeah i probably watched it or
saw a picture and went like i got it
um which is not the right thing to do
there are people like jake farrow and
taran who were like so good at
impressions
uh i i went for more of a vibe
[Laughter]
and then john daly did you play john
daly once bobby did you play him yeah i
think so
yeah during uh like a game show i think
it all blurs together yeah what's your
favorite sketch that you did
on snl bobby oh boy um they all
are amazing right now just for for oh
god is there like a fun sports one
at all it doesn't have to be sports
channing tatum played tom brady
the night before the super bowl of the
giants and i was a
a crazy woman named janet peck and paul
who tried to sleep with him
and it ruined him and that's why they
lost the super bowl i think that might
be one of my favorites
okay so then i guess let me let me go
one last one with you here at snl
the skit that you wished could have made
it that didn't
that uh either you wrote either you
wrote or
or part of the writing or part of the
acting in it or
which one was that for you bob uh every
week you write something that you wish
gets on and it doesn't but
um i i i always wrote like
fantasy things like it was like when i
loved the show lost so when lost was
ending i like wrote like a big thing
you know i was trying to like insert
myself into things that i enjoyed
so that yeah that didn't make it is what
you're saying a bunch yeah every week
something didn't make it that you write
it but probably rightfully so
i've got bobby moynihan here on the rich
eisen show
um so let's talk about uh mr mayor which
again you could stream right here on
on peacock the next day after it airs it
airs on thursday nights
um i was talking about how ted danson is
royalty that's
uh what's what's it like being in a show
with him and holly hunter
two i guess royals of the profession
what's that like
yeah i feel like i'm i'm learning i feel
like i'm getting free acting lessons
from two different two master classes
uh ted's just been on television since
forever and he's
fantastic at it and he's really
wonderful to work with and the crew
and and holly is maybe one of the most
creatively talented people i've ever met
and i love watching her work and
i can't believe i get to do scenes with
them and they're fantastic and
i get to be the idiot that comes in
every 10 minutes and says something
funny
and then uh and then you go home and
then just do it again and then i get to
go home rinse and repeat
and then so what do you like about the
show bobby what do you like about it
um i i i like what i like about it
is what tina fey and robert carlock
wrote it if i was not on it i would be a
fan of the show i would be watching it
anyway
just because of them um but i like that
it's not about politics it's more about
the people
and their relationships that just happen
to be working for the mayor
uh that's pretty fun it's a nice escape
to laugh
in a nice way okay and that's at eight
eastern on thursday nights on nbc you
can catch new episodes of mr mayor again
the next day on peacock
how come you're bibby moynihan on
instagram bobby
how come um exactly uh no no um i uh i
just that's
a nickname and i just thought it was
funny at the time
so it's there was no bobby moynihan
and that was squatting on your name or
something like that you know there
probably will i
i think there is a bobby moynihan but
it's like there's like
one post and it's for an ad for like an
iced tea that doesn't exist or something
i have no idea
right um i just thought it was funny to
get baby moynihan
and probably not the best idea no no
it's uh it's it stands out
that definitely it's it stands out and
it's also you know uh fun to say
um and i'm just looking at some of your
characters in snl gandalf in the hobbit
office i forgot about that one that's
yeah that's a fun one that is a fun one
uh where
the hobbit office is a fantastic
construct
uh hey bobby thanks for the call you uh
really appreciate it thanks for coming
on the show
i really appreciate you calling in and i
look forward to seeing uh
more of mr mayor and uh watching it the
next day here on peacock
thanks for the call brother thank you so
much take care you got it that's
bobby moynihan right here on the show at
bibby moynihan on both twitter and
instagram
here on the rich eisen show